-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, it seems like
supply-chain issues
are causing new problems
every day.
I just read that this holiday
season, there's going to be
a shortage of both real
and artificial Christmas trees.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-It won't be quite the same when
your family is singing carols
around a coat rack
wrapped in lights.
[ Laughter ]
I grew up with an artificial
Christmas tree.
They're the best. You just open
it up like an umbrella.
[ Laughter ]
Instant Christmas.
It smells like the basement.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, this is going viral.
The U.S. Consumer Product
Safety Commission tweeted
a pretty intense graphic
to remind people
to water their Christmas trees.
Take a look at this.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-If you thought getting
your kids to go to sleep
on Christmas Eve was hard
before.
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't look like a message
from the Safety Commission.
It looks like a Christmas album
from Iron Maiden.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, to avoid fires,
water your tree.
But don't worry about
the long, floppy sock
you hang directly
over your fireplace.
[ Laughter ]
And fill it with coal.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I fill mine with gasoline.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Some political news --
Today, President Biden traveled
to the new General Motors
electric-vehicle factory
in Detroit to talk about
his infrastructure plan.
It was Biden's fifth trip
to Michigan as president.
It may not mean much to you,
but right now, Delaware is like,
"Who the hell is she?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, today, the deer-antler guy
was sentenced to 41 months
in prison for his role
in the Capitol riot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right now, he's trying to use
an antler
to lift the keys
off a guard's belt.
[ Laughter ]
Some news from overseas --
Kim Jong-un just made
his first public appearance
in more than a month.
Here he is.
Let's take a look at him.
Wow. Yep.
Apparently, the original
"Matrix" movie
was just released
in North Korea.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-All the guys walking behind him
are like,
"Oh, only you could pull that
off. Yeah.
You look great in pleather."
[ Laughter ]
It took him 10 seconds
to get into that coat
and four bottles of baby powder
to get him out.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that Papa John's
is rebranding
with a new, simplified logo that
doesn't have the apostrophe
in "John's."
-Hmm.
-Yeah, here.
Check out the old logo
on the left
and the new one on the right.
Look at that. Here.
[ Laughter ]
They also removed the word
"pizza" entirely.
[ Laughter ]
They said, "Our lawyers told us
we can't call it that anymore."
[ Laughter ]
-Legally.
-Can we see the logos again?
Yeah, honestly,
it's pretty similar.
And I think that
their new commercial
is a little confusing.
Watch this.
-Here at Papa Johns,
we're proud to introduce
the all-new Papa Johns.
You can forget all about Papa
John because this is Papa John.
So join us at Johns Papas
for some Pizza Johns today.
Just look for the sign that says
Jopapajama's
and ask for me, John Jopapajos.
We'll serve up
some hot Pajo Pajo's
faster than you can say,
"Snohj Apapa."
So see you at
Pohnpohn Japajapa's
under the Papa Jaja Pajpajpaj's
sign.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
Don't you find that confusing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right?
Some more business news --
Apple just announced that
it's launching
a self-service repair program
so customers can fix
their iPhones at home.
[ Cheers ]
Do they really trust us
to fix an iPhone?
[ Laughter ]
The only idea we've come up with
so far
is to stick it in a bag of rice.
And I don't even know
if that works.
But Apple will teach you to do
exactly what they do
in the store --
look at it for 10 seconds
and go,
"We're going to have
to mail this in."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Higgins, you got to see this.
Mark Zuckerberg just unveiled
the new glove from Meta
that will allow you
to feel V.R. objects.
Check this out.
-Why don't you go ahead and try
taking one of those blocks out?
There's a more complicated
interaction
you can do with your hands.
We can even shake hands.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally, the technology
we've all been waiting for --
virtual Jenga.
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
I'm sure that's exactly
what it will be used for.
-Yeah.
-Rolling dice.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Don't come in! Don't come in!
I'm -- I'm playing Jenga!
Don't come in here!"
[ Laughter ]
-You're playing a lot of Jenga.
-I'm playing -- I'm playing Uno.
[ Laughter ]
-Got a can of paint.
-It's a tournament.
[ Laughter ]
-Finally, a stream in Hawaii
that smelled like beer
turned out to have
a high alcohol content.
And officials think it's due to
an accidental spill
from a nearby warehouse.
It sounds like a miracle Jesus
would perform if he was Irish.
[ Laughter ]
[ Irish accent ] "I'm turning
this stream into beer."
[ Laughter ]
"Please don't walk on the beer.
Jesus."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, beer mixed with water,
or as it's also known,
Coors Light.